it has become a true symbol of Christmas
it was performed in the world's best
concert Halls the popular Christmas song
Carol of the Bells the song without
which it would be hard to imagine
Christmas as such these four notes that
can be easily recognized by almost
anyone bring closer together different
parts of the world from the North Pole
to Antarctica from Australia to Alaska
however it is little known that even
though the Carol's famous lyrics were
written by the popular American
conductor Peter wilhowski the author of
its music was a Ukrainian conductor and
composer a true genius Nicola leontovich
and it was an ancient Ukrainian New
Year's folk song called Shadrick that
became the foundation of this
masterpiece centuries ago ukrainians
considered spring the beginning of a new
year that's why the folk lyrics of the
song mentioned swallows the Heralds of
the Season within a hundred years the
Ukrainian song has spread all over the
world turning into an unofficial anthem
of Christmas but before that Shadrick
had gone a long way becoming a symbol of
the Ukrainian fight for independence
from Russia the year is 1919 the first
world war has just ended at the Paris
peace conference the Victorious
countries were trying to create a new
world order in his famous 14 points the
American President Woodrow Wilson
affirmed the inalienable right of
peoples to self-determination in the
background of these Epoch making events
the Baltic states South caucuses Poland
czechia Finland Ukraine and other states
received hope for a just post-war
solution to their National aspirations
the Ukrainian National Republic which
was literally rising from the ashes
declared its independence your parents
old dream has come true from now on the
Ukrainian National Republic becomes
independent from everyone the free
sovereign state of Ukrainian people but
the major countries in Europe and
America did not share the enthusiasm of
ukrainians and that was exploited by the
proficient Russian propaganda machine
that was trying hard to convince the
world that Ukraine didn't exist and
until Lenin's political descendants
credited him with the invention of the
country the Russian ministers at the
time were claiming that Ukraine was
devised by the Austrian general staff
not willing to recognize Ukraine's
Independence Soviet Russia started a
full-scale invasion of Ukraine not only
the Eastern regions of Ukraine were soon
occupied but also the capital cave on
the eve of the invasion Simon petuda
Ukraine's leader at the time sent the
choir on a cultural quest to Europe just
as in today's events while struggling to
match the military power of the opponent
Ukraine realized that the only chance to
survive as a country is to win the
information war and to recruit the
countries of Europe to support Ukraine
so while realizing the significance of
the threat Simon petura began to look
for ways to remind the world that
Ukraine had not only existed for a long
time but it had also done so separately
from Russia it's not a common fact that
pituita just as volodeman zelenski many
years after him had an artistic
background before the war the head of
state and commander-in-chief of the
Ukrainian Army was an art critic theater
reviewer and columnist for Theater
premieres therefore it was decided that
one of the directions of the Ukrainian
Cultural diplomacy should be the most
Universal Medium of all capable of
crossing any borders the music
summoned a composer and conductor
Alexander korschitz and ordered him to
gather a choir within a week practically
a talent show was organized to find the
best choirists against the will of its
creator the Shadrick song also made its
way into the choir's repertoire why
against the will well the composer
mikola leontovich was very hard on
himself a humble music teacher from Tool
chin a small town in the podelia region
leontovich destroyed many of his scores
and worked on shadrick's melodical part
for 10 years and yet the song set off
around the world like a swallow the
first triumphant concert of the
Ukrainian Republican choir took place on
May 11 1919 in the capital of
Czechoslovakia Prague along with
Shadrick the choir performed other
pieces by Nicola listenko Kerala State
senko and Alexander korschitz the
choir's very conductor but all listeners
from Vienna to Brussels from Barcelona
to Paris were in love with the shadow
Carol Shadrick is one of the most
beautiful songs of the program the
London magazine the punch wrote a
masterpiece of folk art a columnist of
the Brussels newspaper leventium admired
the Carol in Vienna the media summarized
Ukraine's cultural maturity must
legitimize its political Independence
for the world Simon pituita's strategy
worked in the following years the
Ukrainian choir kept Gathering Queens
presidents ministers academics and
professors in concert Halls the
Ukrainian choir visited 10 countries
gave more than 200 concerts and caused a
real boom was translated into many
different languages across concert Halls
audiences were chanting long live
Ukraine there were more than half a
thousand reviews in 10 different
languages about Ukraine and Ukrainian
music this was the result of the
European tour of the choir hundreds of
foreign artists politicians and public
Figures were sending letters to the
choir in support of Ukrainian Cultural
and political agency meanwhile a real
catastrophe was taking place in the
homeland of Shadrick while the Ukrainian
National Republic was winning on the
cultural front its military attempts to
force back thousands of Bolsheviks and
the armies of the whites who tried to
restore the Russian Empire failed
completely despite all hopes the
military support to Ukraine was not
provided and for the next 70 years the
country became occupied by Soviet Russia
the political repression started murders
of Ukrainian intelligencia were branded
as purges of those who disagreed with
the regime
suffered a similar fate he was killed in
the middle of a street in Paris in 1921
Nicola leontovich was also killed by an
agent of the all-russian extraordinary
commission leontovich's music was
declared as Irrelevant for the Soviet
reality and the memory of the composer
faded for many decades but Alexander
cautious his choir continued to live and
sowedric in 1922 the choir reached the
Western Hemisphere and not just some
place but the most prestigious concert
venue Carnegie Hall that same night for
the first time ever Americans heard the
melody of their future Favorite
Christmas hit what followed next were
concerts in more than 100 American
cities everywhere Shadrick was The
Encore as in Europe leontovich's Carol
is not only a tour hit but also a symbol
of the Ukrainian fight for independence
Singh serval Ukraine sing little bird
the spring Euro waiting for will come
Brazilian academic Henrik cuello Neto
rode after the the premiere of Shadrick
in Rio de Janeiro but ukrainians had to
wait for a while for their Supreme
Russian winter was raining on their lap
the Kremlin was continuing to erase
Ukrainian Intelligentsia star of
Ukrainian peasants and consistently
destroying anything that could remind
the world of Ukraine however stadlock
preserved the memory of its Homeland in
1936 the American composer and conductor
of Ukrainian descent Peter J wilhowski
added Chadwick to the repertoire of his
school choir and presented the song on
the popular NBC radio show after the
premiere American music teachers
bombarded wilhowski with requests to
send the sheet music of Shadrick in
November 1936 he published the song in
the New York music publisher Carl Fisher
music calling it Carol of the Bells in
the score he notes this is a Ukrainian
Christmas Carol music by Nicola
leontovich lyrics and Arrangement by
Peter wilhowski that's how a Ukrainian
swallow turned into American Bells
became Carol of the Bells The Melody of
Nicola leontovich first became a
Christmas Anthem in the U.S and later in
the entire world to this tune people
play basketball make movies celebrate
Christmas and make content for tick tock
in the UK Shadrick is sometimes called
the New Year's Serenade in Latin America
a song of great magic and in Canada a
newly discovered Sphinx why did the work
of the Ukrainian composer become so
popular this melody is timeless expands
from the times of paganism when the
surrounding nature was a source of
people's inspiration to the era of
American Hollywood it graced box office
hits such as Harry Potter Die Hard the
immortal Simpsons and many many more
even among ukrainians very few people
knew about the true origin of this
masterpiece and its important cultural
and political Mission many heard the
song for the first time in the Home
Alone movie released in 1990 for almost
a century Shadrick lived across the
Atlantic where the song became a Chris
Christmas Anthem uniting people in their
faith a hundred years later a missile of
those same Russian occupiers hit a
residential building in cave located on
Alexandra korsche Street Russia is
attempting to replay its absurd record
about denasification and the lack of
grounds for Ukrainian statehood but this
time the world has no doubts in
Ukraine's sovereignty owing among other
things to shadrick's contribution a
century ago the foundation of cultural
diplomacy created by Simon petuda
remains a pillar for today's successes
Ukrainian songs and culture in general
continue bringing new victories that
enforce and supplement gains in other
areas diplomatic and Military to help
ukrainians defend their home and secure
the main Victory the victory Of Life
over death Freedom's triumph over
subjugation
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]